It's time to play Vine-HS.
-Vine-HS.
-(cheering)
As the old saying goes,
Doug loves movies,
and true movie lovers like Doug
get bummed out
when they think
of all the classic films
that are trapped
on obsolete VHS tapes.
Um, those are cassettes
not deemed worthy enough
to be ripped onto Netflix
or PornHub
and they're just
kind of floating some...
I'm just throwing out
random, uh...
But thanks to Vine accounts
like Grimy Ghost!
and It Came From The VCR,
we can revisit the weirdest gems
ever put to tape.
So I'm gonna show you
a bizarre clip from an old VHS,
and then for 250 points,
I want you to tell me
what the next line of dialogue
is, all right?
All right, first up,
these aging Anglos.
I can't seem
to get it up properly.
Are you less moist, for example?
-Yes, exactly.
Doug.
Yes, we are both dry as (bleep).
All right, points. Points.
Erica.
I used to squirt and now
it's more of a light misting.
And then you just see her...
(hisses) Excuse me!
-Points to Erica Rhodes.
-Cup o' tea.
Very well played. Uh, next up,
this cutting critique.
Color isn't that great
and this horse is fat,
looks a little bit overweight.
This horse'll never
get my money any day.
(bell dings)
What a (bleep) dick.
Rory.
Okay, thank you,
Tim in Pontiac, Michigan.
That's the last time
we go to the phones.
Points. Points.
Erica.
And the horse looks even worse.
-Oh!
-Points.
Next up, these fish lovers.
Come on, Eric,
you've had your lunch.
(babbles)
(bell dings)
Doug.
He goes on to say...
(babbling)
And then the dolphin goes,
"Why are you speaking Porpoise?"
Points.
Yeah, that's very racist.
We're not the same.
Rory Scovel.
Cut! James, look, if you can't
remember the lines,
just call for them.
Do not dolphin scat again.
-Points, points.
-(babbling)
Finally, this lurid embrace.
(bell dings)
You guys have never seen,
uh, Spider-Boyz II Men?
Uh...
Doug Benson.
I don't know if there's
any dialogue, Chris,
but here comes Spider-Man.